Lynnette starts off this hour in Raleigh
North Carolina hi Lynette how are you
hey Dave are you doing better than I
deserve what's up in your world well my
son actually suggested that I give you a
call because I have about $90,000 in a
traditional IRA which that to me is a
foreign language right there and I've
been hearing over and over that I need
to put it in a Roth IRA I have
absolutely no idea how to do that
I mean I'm earning virtually nothing on
dividends for this I don't know what I'm
doing and I need your help okay
well the a Roth nor a traditional are
not an investment they are how the
investment is treated for taxes so you
can have a bad investment
in either one or a good investment
inside of either one an example of a bad
investment in any kind of an IRA inside
of a Roth or traditional would be just
buying it at the bank and putting it in
the equivalent of a CD and it earns
nothing right okay in the example of a
good investment inside of either one
that I suggest is growth stock type
mutual funds and I personally spread my
type of investments across four of those
categories a growth a growth in income
and aggressive growth and then
international and I spread it across
like that so but it's all mutual funds
in other words and and so it's going to
get more like returns more like what the
stock market does which is a whole lot
more on average than the CD world is
okay so now how the investment is
treated for taxes is the difference
between traditional and Roth or not
being in there at all now if you bought
mutual funds not inside of either one as
they made money and paid the money to
you you would pay taxes on that gain
okay okay since it's inside under the
coat of under the tenth of an IRA you're
not going to pay money in either case as
it grows until you take it okay now the
difference
difference is the traditional IRA you
get a tax deduction on the money when
you put it in so it's what we call
before tax dollars going in okay and so
like if you put five thousand five
hundred dollars into a traditional IRA
this year you would take that as a
deduction on your taxes so you would not
pay taxes yet on that five thousand five
hundred dollars you follow me okay yes
then it grows tax-deferred in a
traditional meaning you don't pay taxes
until you take it out so the whole thing
when you take it out is taxable okay if
you take it out early its taxable with a
penalty so let's play pretend for a
second and let's look into the future
because it's a great question not only
for you but for our listening audience
okay you got nine thousand bucks in
there if you add nothing to it and you
had it in mutual funds and it made
twelve percent
it might make that much it might make
less it might make more how old are you
now I'm sixty okay and if you did that
for 10 years until seventy okay then
that would grow to about four hundred
and seventy thousand dollars in that ten
year period of time okay let me do that
again cuz I'm not sure I did that right
I didn't do that right I'm not I'm okay
I think I think that is a while yeah
yeah Wow yeah let's see here you know I
did no I think I did it wrong I'm gonna
put them up I'm gonna check my numbers
here yeah that's more like it's about
three hundred thousand okay so it would
about triple okay
give or take the whatever the rate of
return is but let's say it made it went
from 92 to 290 all right okay then
that'd be a $200,000 gain you're going
to pay taxes on the ninety because you
haven't paid taxes on what you put in
there already and you're going to pay
taxes on the growth inside a traditional
IRA okay now yeah jump over to the other
one the Roth our oth is named for the
senator that passed the bill senator
William Roth that caused this to be in
effect that's where the name comes from
it is after-tax dollars going in no tax
deduction on the money that goes in it
grows tax-free ow
so you would not pay taxes on the money
you would pay taxes on the money you put
in but you would never pay taxes on the
growth okay so in our example if you put
if you put ninety thousand in there and
if it grew to two hundred ninety
thousand you would have no taxes on the
two hundred thousand growth okay you
waited ten years to take it out okay and
if it grew to that now so that's in our
example now the ninety thousand however
has not been taxed so if you roll it
from a traditional to a Roth that money
is taxable now so you pay taxes on 90
grand now to keep from paying taxes on
200 later if you put it in an investment
and leave it alone at the time we talked
about Wow does that make sense so your
tax your pratt taxes probably be like
thirty thousand bucks do you have any
other money yes you have an extra thirty
thousand you could lay your hands on say
that again you have an extra thirty
thousand you could lay your hands on to
pay the taxes with that are caused by
rolling this from a traditional right
probably not okay then you have to use
some of this money to do that okay and
you could do that but it is no real
benefit much so if you can and you could
do some of it this year and some of it
next okay so I mean that that makes
great sense
so you're saying yeah see that's the
thing is paying taxes on ninety thousand
dollars you're going to only leave it
alone three years or five years it's not
gonna be worth it I just leave it where
it is other than I would roll it from a
traditional bad investment traditional
IRA to a good investment traditional I
read where you got it it didn't work and
you need to move it into something else
but right yeah I would not move to a
Roth unless you're going to leave it
alone about ten years which I probably
will okay so if I didn't have sir what
would you do if I had the thirty if I
don't have this much do you have extra
not counting your emergency fund
gosh isn't this awful because I don't
know my husband and I are both retired
we both have tension okay well let let's
pretend let's pretend you two how much
what's your income um I got two hundred
maybe okay so you could easily you could
easily cashflow fifteen thousand this
year and 15,000 next year okay so if you
want to move half of it one year half of
it another year and good cash flow and
just cash flow the taxes that way the
whole ninety goes to work for you and
you've already paid the taxes on that
any so you won't pay taxes on it later
when you take it out and you'll never
pay taxes on the growth oh I love it
okay oh I love it that is yeah oh wow
that's going to make this and leave it
in there for ten years or more and other
than making what was my dividend my
dividend was something like oh I don't
even know yeah well you need to have it
invested in something better whether you
leave it in a traditional or whether you
move it to a Roth that's the thing so
get in touch with one of our endorsed
local providers our LPS at the front
page of Dave Ramsey com click on ALP for
investing they'll sit down with you and
teach you like I just did how all this
works and then you'll know what you are
doing that's very important with
investing and then you decide based on
that what you're going to do but that's
how it all works this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income
Oh